déjà cinq jours que la Russie est entrée
en guerre contre l'ucléaire l'Ukraine
des explosions ont été entendus ce matin
à Kiev rapporte le service d'état
ukrainien chargé des communications
spéciales et de la protection
d'information qui va passer une nouvelle
nuit sous couvre-feu intégrale les
habitants se tèrent chez eux dans des
bunkers ou dans le métro les rues de la
capitale sont quasi désertes et vous
allez le voir sur une carte les combats
sont en cours à différents endroits du
pays il y a les villes tombées aux mains
des Russes et celles qui résiste notre
envoyé spécial Clovis calazari nous
raconte ces dernières heures passées
dans son bunker
les civils et les journalistes ont
interdiction de sortir dehors pendant
cette période de couvre-feu qui dure
jusqu'à lundi sinon on peut nous tirer
dessus c'est ce qu'on déclarait les
autorités et du coup on passait
énormément de temps ici dans des abris
comme celui où je me trouve où il y a
des journalistes mais aussi des
Ukrainiens de tout âge il y a des
enfants il y a des adultes des vieilles
dames des gens qui sont venus prendre
refuge ici depuis plusieurs jours depuis
le début des opérations alors quelle est
la situation on entend régulièrement des
détonations des tiers des coups de feu
des artillerie des tirs nourris
particulièrement la nuit dernière où on
a aussi vu de loin des requêtes et on a
entendu beaucoup beaucoup de coups de
feu une situation particulièrement
volatile ici dans le pays et à Kiev même
et ici il y a bien sûr les soldats
Ukrainiens qui ont pris les armes pour
défendre la patrie mais aussi de
nombreux Ukrainiens des enseignants des
coiffeur de toute profession des gens
qui sont là pour dans les rues de Kiev
pour défendre la patrie il y a des
distributions d'armes devant certains
commissariats à certaines bases bien
précises et je peux vous dire qu'il y a
aussi énormément de monde qui préparent
des cocktails Molotov aucun où ils
verraient des soldats russes les
Ukrainiens se félicitent déjà des bilans
si on peut dire des bilans selon le
ministère de la Défense ukrainien et
bien il y aurait plus de 4000 soldats
russes de tuer depuis le début des
opérations et énormément de blindés et
de chat qui aurait été détruit ce sont
les chiffres
ukrainiens et donc pour l'instant les
Ukrainiens tiennent bon arrivent à
repousser les assauts russes pour
combien de temps c'est la question
Bruno Dar